the audition is the job
that is the job
let's say you get a call right now from
your agent and you have a big audition
tomorrow what's the call like what
happens
I'm not sure what's the well first of
all I don't get a call I get an email oh
okay so it's not it's not ring ring no
there's none of that anymore it's all
impersonal I'm afraid
um
interesting because
now you have to self-tape everything
so it's not like oh I have this audition
I'm going to go to Warner Brothers at
four o'clock to this building to this
room that doesn't happen anymore I don't
know if that'll ever happen again so you
have to not only think okay I have to
look at this
I also in my case and I don't know if
everyone's like this I go do I want to
do this is this something everybody want
to do because I don't care anymore and
I'm in a different place in my life if I
don't want to do it or if it doesn't
feel right I'll go I'm going to pass on
that and they seem to be okay with that
but
the first thing I do is that I freak out
a little bit because I know there's a
timeline
and I know that oh I have to drop
everything and I have to get this done I
don't tape at home
because I'm not good at it and I hire
that out I have a guy I go to I pay him
whatever it is 40 50 bucks he does it
it's great and I don't have to worry
about that because that would drive me
crazy I'm not really good at that
so then I just really have to think
about uh what is this how do I do this
how do I get off book for this the
timelines as I said earlier are very
short
so I really have to decide whether I
want to do it when I was producing
um the pilot I produced this summer
I'm on set we're out in San Dimas it's
like 105 degrees
so hot and I get an email with a 14 page
audition that was due the next day
I just said two things I said first of
all thank you
second of all can't be done
because I'm producing this thing and I'm
on set and lastly
I'm not sure if 14 pages can be done in
24 hours anyway but it won't be a
problem because I can't do this one
so it's it's different everybody's
um the audition is the job
that is the job
and that's the way I try to teach actors
to look at it you have a job it's this
audition you have to get it filmed you
have to turn it in that's the job now
you made that job may continue
you may get a call and say oh we want
then you may get a chance to earn some
money doing that job
but the audition is the job and and it's
um
there's not a lot of room for error I'm
afraid I mean it's just it's so I think
because now they're I think I I don't
know if casting directors will get angry
with me but
it's the only people who's not tired of
Zoom are the casting people so they they
if if they were going to have see 30
people in their office on a Wednesday
well they don't need that extra room
they might not need that extra
assistance because they're going to see
more than 30 people because they just
send out these tapes
and I don't know if they watch all of
them
I don't know
some of them say they do and I believe
that but some probably don't
do you think in some ways though the
self-taping is easier in that you don't
have to get in your car or take the bus
or Uber or Lyft it's easier in that
respect it's also easier it's not easier
for me because I'm old and I'm set in my
ways and I don't like it but that's
immaterial it's easier for the the the
digital natives the young people who
never knew a life without a phone or a
camera
um and are really skilled at it many of
them very skilled
it's kind of easier for them because
they
can do the audition until they get it
the way they want it
in the old days you'd walk into the room
and you might not
your first take might not be good and
that may be all you get thank you thank
you for coming in
and you walk out and you do the you do
your best job in the car on the way home
so yes that aspect of it is in some ways
an improvement
but what's missing is the human element
you don't meet people you don't it's all
on that little box
then you're also
not dealing with a sea of agendas and
energies around you true yeah I mean I
think it's generational people my age uh
I don't particularly like it I'll I do
it and I do a good job with it and I
understand that how it has to be done
and
um but you also like you send it off
into the ether
and you generally hear nothing
nothing
and so you don't even get an attaboy or
a good
you know not that we all need a pat on
the back but
um sometimes you know like when you go
in and you meet someone in person and
you do a really good job with your
audition you may not get that role but
you may get something from that office
because they liked you
if they didn't even see the I mean they
may watch all the tapes but they maybe
only watch 30 seconds and go no that no
wrong wrong person wrong whatever
so I don't know I mean I'd actually like
to know I'd like to be a fly on the wall
some of those offices and see what they
do and so I know because we hired a very
good casting director for the pilot we
did and they did an incredible job but
they're also one of the better they're
been around a long time and they're one
of the better uh casting offices
so I think it's like anything there's
there's the cream and then there's
everything else
what do you think of people posting
their audition tape online as part of
their social media I don't like it do
you think it breaks sort of a code
that's interesting question
um
well first of all sometimes there are
shows that are non-disclosures so
they're they haven't even aired yet
or sometimes they will send you what we
call dummy sides
do you know what that is
I don't but so dummy sides would be like
you're auditioning for this character
and they'll say these this isn't really
the script but it's it's sides that are
like that character
and you you have no choice but to just
play what you're given you know but I
know I posting people post way too much
online about everything but I I I don't
know that's a really good question
everyone you know a lot of people just
want to be seen
and want to present their best life in
that way and
I don't know I don't think it's a good I
don't probably think it's a good idea
you know particularly if uh I know
people who do that a lot actually now
that I think of it I would never do that
yeah I was just wondering how casting
directors think about it if it's not
embargoed or whatever yeah well if it's
embargo obviously you should never do
that but um
there's a guy that I know who's a very
good actor he's working quite a bit he
also as a as a side gig does taping for
people
and I've actually taped with him and
he's great and he did this thing I
thought was really cool because he
booked some job on the show I don't know
a guest star role of some sort and he
took his audition tape and intercut it
with the actual footage from the show to
see show you this is what I did in this
scene here's the scene as it was filmed
and I thought that was actually very
instructive and cool but that was also
done the show was had already been aired
he had access to that footage
theoretically I guess
and that was actually very teachable and
instructive to see what he did that got
that role and how it looked when it was
filmed that's kind of interesting but
yeah posting just in general
people are crazy with that stuff
when you do get this person to film your
self tape
um are you there reading lines off of
them or they're just an eye line to you
uh the place that I use
he's an actor himself and he's very good
and so he is the eye line I mean now
now we're getting technical but that's
good uh sometimes in a in an audition
you might have three people you're
talking to and the eye lines get a
little crazy like so I often say just
like pick two
have two uh have two eye lines other or
unless somebody's in the back and you
can talk to someone back there that's
different but yeah no that guy would
read with me and uh
he's actually quite good and he will
Coach a little bit I mean which I
appreciate
he doesn't overstep but I think that's
smart most people don't do that they
just
they just you know set up the camera and
go
but uh yeah no he'll read with me he's a
very he's very good at it so I think
it's
Tech you know the technical stuff
is really important the eye lines and
all that stuff
it's just key and props
they always tell you don't bring props I
said bring a prop if it helps you I I
worked with somebody yesterday
she's playing a bartender and so she had
glasses and she had a rag she threw over
her shoulder so that all helps there's
nothing wrong with that
they used to say no he can't do that
all these rules are very fluid now
right
what does it mean for an actor to make
bold choices with their character
I mean that that is a cliche let's say
make a bold Choice make a strong choice
but with every cliche there generally is
a grain of Truth or wouldn't have become
a cliche
um
I think that it's like
um if you're at the top of a mountain
and you pour some water down the
mountain it's going to go it's going to
find its way down that's the obvious way
that is the way down the water is going
to find a little rivulets and it's going
to flow a certain way and most scenes
particularly if you don't have a lot of
time
you're just going to play it down the
middle because you don't have time to
really explore it and get deeper with it
I I think trying to make the less
obvious choice the choice that may not
be actually on the page
you have to understand who the end user
is the end user is the casting director
and they're looking at lots of tapes and
they're looking at lots of versions of
the same scene over and over and over
again and most people
because of either lack of imagination or
lack of time are going to kind of play
it the same way so if you can find a way
that's Justified that's earned where you
can play something a little bit off to
the side of the page not down the middle
of the page
that's what I would call a bold choice
and a smart choice
you don't want to do that just to be
different
it has to be earned and it has to feel
like it has some Fidelity to the
character and the story but I think
that's
um that's how I would Define what a bold
choice is something that does not go
down the middle because most of the time
as I said lack of time lack of
imagination and they're watching all
these tapes they're all we did that when
I cast the pilot I mean a lot of the
tapes were like
they're all kind of played the same way
and the the one person who may play it a
little differently
jumps out for whatever reason maybe it's
not smart maybe it's not right but it's
different and so it's a little like um
I like sports analogies
um
like in baseball the great Warren spawn
the winning winning is left-hander in
the history of baseball said that the
pitcher's job is to upset the hitter's
timing and the hitter's job is to upset
the pitcher's timing so I think that our
job is to sort of
break open the timing of that scene a
little bit change the rhythm of it a
little bit if you can find a way to do
that because they're going to hear it a
certain way every time over and over
again if you can find a way to
creatively and smartly
break up the Rhythm I'm I've words and
Rhythm very important to me in my own
work and and when I when I teach them
when I coach so that's what I would say
would be a bold choice
let's say you've already booked a job
now you're on set
how bold you get or no that breaks that
that disturbs the other actor in the
scene and you're upstaging someone
that's really case-by-case basis it
depends on the set if you have a really
loose improvisational set you can do
that you can try that I I worked on Curb
Your Enthusiasm where there's no script
basically there's a story there's there
are scenes and so uh everyone's you know
a lot of funny people Larry David Ed
Bagley Richard Lewis Jeff Garland
you know they're also going to try out
stuff that's funny and some of it will
hit and some of it won't hit that's an
extreme example of where you can be bold
and try something else that's great I
don't think we're going to use that
uh but it just is different on a on a
show that is
a well-oiled machine a weekly kind of
what I call Factory television those
those shows that just go week to week
they have a template
a visual template and a tone template
that is is established that's what they
do they play to that they have like a
few watch uh SWAT
every seven minutes someone's going down
a hallway with a gun in the dark I mean
that's part of the template I'm
exaggerating but not that much so you
have to understand that and you can't on
a show that has a really strong
uh template you kind of can't do that
it just depends on the circumstance but
it's fun to play and it's fun to do
stuff that's different and out there but
you just have to kind of know your
audience and know what world you're in